[Music]
you know some people they feel really
bad
you said everything happened to me
knowing sometimes I feel like you want
to cry but you can't kind of shock
sometimes I didn't think all of these
people would care people around the
world millions everyone is talking about
making a murderer and the trials of
Steven Avery it's not all one somebody
is convicted we have to move mountains
to get out of prison
our task now is to up an entire system
the favors the prosecutors do we want
the right person convicted yeah but
that's secondary Teresa's gone there's
nothing else you can do about that
prominent attorney Kathleen Zellner best
known for overturning wrongful
convictions has taken the Avery case
I have one goal and that's to overturn
the conviction of Steven Avery
why would someone falsely confess to a
crime that they didn't commit they
wanted this information in a worth way
so Brendan thinks if I tell them what
they want to hear I'm gonna go home the
prosecution's case was trees had never
left the property but the last call
pings off a cellphone tower miles away
from the Avery property seventy to
eighty percent of people were murdered
and murdered by someone they know each
of those individuals have to be looked
at as suspect if there's a lot based on
that bullet this is critical there's an
abundance of evidence this could flip
the whole case
if the conviction is overturned and they
try to do a retrial
do they have much of a case I don't
think man talk is ever going to heal
from this I know they want to be a happy
family again like we used to be I want
to see if I can put that back together
I've built me a big house so I can take
care of them I want to make them happy
long as they're here and that's what I'm
scared about but this case is solid if
he's guilty
I'll fail
you